We are responsible
for our own pleasure.
I'm responsible for my orgasm.
You're responsible
for your orgasm.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's not about your partner
giving you an orgasm.
It's about us understanding what
we need and what feels good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I want to get rid of all
the shame we have around sex
and talking about sex.
It should be like we are
talking about the weather.
It's like, overcast with
a chance of orgasms.
I'm going to teach
you everything
I've learned in 15 years so
you can learn how to explore
your sex life,
your relationships,
and your sexuality because
pleasure is your birthright.
We all deserve pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This class is for
everybody; every body.
Take that next step
towards deciding what
sex and sexuality means to you.
Here are my three Ts for healthy
communication around sex:
timing, turf, and tone.
Kegels, kegels, kegels. I don't
really care how you say them,
but you have to
know how to do them.
And yes, penis owners
can do kegels.
They're-- They
were so surprised.
Like, I thought that's
just for vulvas.
Nope.
And let me tell you this.
Blow your mind.
Your wetness level is not
an indicator of arousal.
When a vulva owner adds lube
to any sexual experience,
they're 80% more
likely to orgasm.
Just a little bit of lube.
God, I love lube.
Your sexuality and how
you want to have sex
is entirely up to you.
You get to decide.
It's not about culture or
religion or your family
or your neighbor,
and I guarantee
your neighbor's freakier
than you think they are.
If you're not truly
fulfilling your sexual desires
and living true to your
authentic self,
it's going to impact
your entire life.
I'm Emily Morse, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]